vous a demandé de nous donner votre
photo la plus ratée celle que vous
auriez aimé faire disparaître et comme
je sais qu'à un moment quelqu'un dire
wayne et toi tu joue pas le jeu et tout
ça je me mouille jamais hein donc pour
détendre tout le monde moi la photo que
j'aurais oublié c'est celle là
voilà quelle est la recette choqué par
tout le projet on s'est moqué de ma
coiffure
c'était il ya presque 28 ans est allé
danser même à l'époque c'était pas la
mode
je crois que c'est à cette époque là que
ma mère m'a dit tu étais beau quand tu
étais petit et à la rage peut être pas
que s'agrandisse vous avez tous mieux
aujourd'hui c'est ça ma l'incroyable jeu
surtout un budget maquillage énorme
vous avez une très belle blanc quand
même sur cette fois pas du tout pas beau
ça veut dire que maintenant l'aider dans
sa tâche pour l'adolescence pour ça que
je suis là je sais que quinze ans qu un
seul homme dans la vingtaine j'avais 20
ans et même plus l'âge bête
je suis un peu fragile vous étiez ivre
sous substances alors je vais vous dire
la vérité cgt parti que des amis en
vacances et le dernier jour des vacances
on s'est aperçu qu'on n'avait pas fait
de photos donc on a fait toutes les
photos en deux heures et là on jouait
c'était l'époque ce n'était pas du
numérique on pouvait pas effacé si ces
camps après développement ont scandé
compte qu'on n'aurait pas dû alors donc
ça c'était ma photo la photo dossier de
daniel qu'elle aurait voulu effacer
c'est celle là j'aurais veut même pas
regardé est ce que quelqu'un un
commentaire ou est ce qu'on pense à la
suite
intello les traits aime cultiver
quand on la voit sur ce plateau on se
dit obligatoirement que c'est un
accident du travail dans les couloirs
mais non comme elle est très souple elle
réussit le pas fait grand écart entre
les émissions populaires et les
émissions bête +12 si vous voulez tout
savoir son programme préfet c'est blaise
pascal le grand frère
[Rires]
c'est pourquoi je suis pour la peau ni
me dit moi elle va trouver que je ne
pouvais pas parce que ce soir j'étais
avec vous la laponie
c'est maintenant je sais pas du tout
parce que vous n'aviez pas gagner votre
place et simplement
alors j'ai tout fait pour gagner ma pré
ne voulais pas gagner ah oui ça c'est
vrai la loose d'accession directe
alors vous vous demandez une faute au
dossier alors ce qui était sexuelle
photogénique ont été chercher nous mêmes
oui vous avez bien fait donc on est
tombé là dessus vous allez retrait très
concentré non mais on n'a pas trouvé
pire regardez un match incroyable entre
djoko et kassianov vous souvenez même
des matchs ouais bah oui c'est important
quand même le tennis mais vous avez une
tête différentes par match book content
parce que dès qu'on ne s'en sortait pas
d'accord très belles anecdotes
ouais alors lui oui je fais les quelques
années pendant près de cinq ans il fut
le fringant directeur des programmes de
france télévisions et les à l'est de la
ville ont conduit dans tpm et reçu de
cette descente aux enfers des aléas du
direct
forcément en mémoire un choc ils doivent
a encore en mémoire son look des années
france de regarder ces pièces à
conviction parce que la qualité à france
2 c'était ça bah oui ça faisait
dirigeants pas donné mais c'est vrai
quand je vous ai connu nicolas je vous
dire j'ai eu deux émissions à france 2
et qui les a mis à l'antenne c'est
nicolas
cette opération est meilleure que celle
là où est ce qu'on peut voir la seconde
où il est un peu plus jeune a fait son
show voilà d'énergie le méchoui bon je
m'en sors jamais très bien mais voilà
vous êtes magnifique nicolas ses façades
mais parce que maintenant je connais des
gens qui l'ont découvert dans l'émission
cette année il y pense qu'il a toujours
eu un loupé de naufragés dit le désert
mais en fait non avant c'était autre
chose
là on sent l'école de commerce en a qui
ont raté c'est quand il est maintenant
vous avez des amis ont fait d'apprendre
à la connaître
alors je conseille à aucun aléas du
direct de se pointer sur plateau parce
qu'elle son caractère je serai capable
de me mettre une droite c'est la seule
chroniqueuse qui n'a pas besoin de frais
qui paie d'un micro pour se faire
entendre
la michelle obama française
chaque échange c'est quoi cette
présentation de mes mandats dix ans sur
balles et pas la même personne
j'adore à rien mais l'oci a alors si je
touche plus à rien je vais quand même
montré votre photo non petit une photo
je pense que ça ce n'est pas si vous la
connaissez elle est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
michelle obama en fin de soirée
mais les sous produits on va dire ça
c'est tout c'est juste la fête dit m
heureusement que vous soutenir quand
même lui quand j'ai commencé à tpm paix
j'étais assis à sa gauche un embout
table en un an personne ne m'a jamais vu
à l'écran car j'étais caché par ses
choix depuis on lui a permis à un
toilettage et des magnifiques les ailes
la vie nous avait séparés sur les
plateaux télé mais nous nous retrouvons
enfin ce soir christophe cariou très
content de vous retrouver
et l'élu et vous vont très bien ouais
bah oui ben non on ne sait pas la
coquetterie c'est juste que je vieillis
j'aimerais tellement les maîtres du pour
faire joli mais ces gens là bas c'est ça
à savoir dire non ça nous rajeunit pas
on peut dire aussi que toutes les vannes
raté que vous vouliez pas faire je
voulais piqué et je passais pour un gros
abruti à l'antenne alors la vérité c'est
que j'étais assis à côté de lui
j'arrivais de n'importe quoi à l'antenne
8x intéressant de le répéter c'est son
problème
comme c'est son problème si nous a
fourni cette photo
[Applaudissements]
non
passons à autre chose la jeune femme qui
arrivait très précieuses car elle sait
tout faire
journaliste chroniqueuse rédactrice en
chef les piliers de bar elle peut même
passer chez buick est de proposer la
moquette ou vous livrer une pizza
si les allées la vie s'acharne sur vous
c'est la personne qu'il faut avoir dans
ses contacts
la dame du bois emilie lopez je précise
par la dame du bois de boulogne
c'est sûrement que je dois donner ma
fille et vous emilie c'est pas vous qui
avez pris la photo
regardez je sais c'est tout ce que je
n'ai pas encore donné la parole tout ce
que vous trouvez à dire s'il ya du monde
au bal c'est très joli
parce que même quand vous entendez comme
ça va être bien cette forte d'une
émission on a eu on était passé à la
maison prendre l'apéro puis la paire au
salon rouge en finissant vous non non
non non non non non là on a enfin un tel
soutien programme familial pas tout de
suite mais j'ai rien à aller baiser
durant ce monsieur qui fait des blagues
douteuses a fait de nos petits aléas du
quotidien une émission phare du paysage
audiovisuel français avec vidéo gag
à l'époque on pouvait encore rire d'un
enfant oublié sur une bande d'arrêt
d'urgence ou mieux que je suis du 4ème
étage comédie de la comédie il a promis
de nous raconter la foi ou ou farouk lgv
à la pâte sur la jambe droite
d'alexandre debanne
wallon bernard bien je serai heureux
d'être là comme tous les vents forts
maintenant avec toi intéressant comme
discussion tu voulais dire c'est que
quand vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
france 2 gt avec vous oui ils étaient
ensemble sur des places si je peux vous
donner un conseil ne prenait jamais
bernard l'émission est amené à s'arrêter
très vite il pourrait sortir alors ce
soir mais je garde j'aime trop bernard
way et vous avez trouvé une photo où
papa c'est très dur
regardez sa maison il m'a dit me lancer
là dessus parce que moi je comprend pas
le projet non plus la dent mais c'est
mignon juste voir ses favoris fille oui
c'est farouk bien sûr ces femmes ou
alors je veux bien c'était oman bellevue
et non à la saint tropez d'esprit était
intelligent ce chien très très
intelligente d'accord mais même s'il est
intelligent
est ce qu'un chien a besoin d'un
arrosoir donc ça veut dire que ce
n'était pas pour lui
[Applaudissements]
raconter les coulisses c'est le faudra a
dit attends ça suffit pas je vais vous
dire j'ai sincèrement touchée de voir
mon chien que j'ai tant aimé et il est
très beau là et non on s'amusait
beaucoup en était en plus inclusive et
du coup j'ai eu à mener tous les jouets
nécessaire parce qu'il mord des tous
regardé le bout de l'arroseur est oui ça
va prendre une heure donc je non c'était
mignon c'était bien le match et sa ble
ment bernard il faisait pas de chatenay
cgt pour moi j'étais lou méjean maire dé
tous les gens de l'hôtel ambassador mais
bien sûr